[Musique]
son sourire lorsque notre attention a
été attirée par un article de journal le
gouvernement ne prendra pas de vacances
cet été
un exemple héroïque qui nous a donné une
idée patriotique que nous vous
recommande
pourquoi ne pas passer vos vacances sur
les champs elysées entre les champs
elysées une quelconque station balnéaire
il n'y a vraiment aucune différence on
fait un petit volet way à aller on se
dérouiller aller
[Musique]
et puis c'est l'heure du bain dans une
eau qui n'est pas moi limpide que celle
de saint tropez
yann au contraire là au moins vous êtes
certain de ne pas revenir le corps
recouvert de goudron à on est toujours
un peu frileux n'est ce pas un plaisir
agréable que de tromper son corps
d'athlète dans l'ondam r
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se change comme à la plage sans se
gêner pour les publics il ya les cabines
téléphoniques
la bronzette ça marche aussi bien qu'à
la boule et il n'y a pas de raison le
soleil est le même partout
ou simplement prendre quelques
précautions élémentaires
[Musique]
et puis on peut se livrer aux mêmes
films plaisanterie au même innocence
galéjade que dans les stations les plus
chics
m
[Musique]
pour les repas pas de problème c'est
beaucoup moins cher au bord de la mer et
on retrouve les mêmes produits
rien n'arrive à jeter
l'arrivage proche entre autres trois
cheveux proche au quotidien c'est à dire
patients ont digéré la sieste est ce
qu'on n'est pas aussi tranquille qu'à
deauville il qu'à cannes alors deux
points auto show ping ah oui qu'on peut
trouver la moindre différence puisque ce
sont les mêmes commerçants qui ouvre des
boutiques en été sur la plage et l'hiver
la montat
[Musique]
pour terminer la journée à la pêche et
nous avait autant de chances de sortir
une seule des chances des risées que du
port de nice
[Applaudissements]
alors n'hésitez pas faites comme nous
passés avec le gouvernement vos vacances
à paris
la seule plage d'europe équipé d'un
métaux
[Musique]